if you go on lifts website right now
which says drivers can make $35 per hour
is that realistic a few weeks ago I
spent a week driving for lyft to find
out all right it is 12:30 and I'm
logging in to my left app to start my
first lyft job of the day driver mode is
on and so far nothing is happening I
drove for 50 hours at 54 passengers and
I made just under $600 which works out
to about 12 bucks an hour and that's
before subtracting the cost of gas a big
reason for my low earnings was that I
spent a lot of time waiting around so
with the traditional salaried position
you work your 40 hours and it's a
company's job to make sure that you have
enough work for it to be worth your
salary with this kind of business I as
an independent contractor I'm on my own
hi you know sit here for the next 5 or 6
or 7 hours and nobody wants a taxi ride
I'm just out that money I got Tuesday
morning I drove for about three hours
and didn't get a single passenger and so
that was pretty frustrating so the day
that one best was on Saturday I worked
about 10 hours and I made a 163 dollars
after gas it was about fourteen dollars
an hour why was Saturday my best day for
one thing I had passengers in my car 35
percent of the time a higher percentage
than any other day second four of my 14
rides had prime time bonuses where
passengers are charged a premium of
twenty five to a hundred percent still
$14 an hour isn't great and it's a lot
less than the $35 lyft is promoting the
fundamental issue is that right now at
least the roads are crowded with people
offering rides now that I'm looking
around I'm noticing that I have a lot of
competitors around me that's partly
because both lyft and uber are
aggressively recruiting drivers well I
only earned about $600 from customers
lyft was running a promotion in November
that guaranteed divers would make at
least $30 an hour so lyft paid me
another $900 out of their own pocket as
uber lyft throw a lot of money at
drivers to drive it's expanding the
number of drivers in the market that
means the drivers spend more time
sitting around and so they actually make
glass they need to grow quickly in order
to compete with uber and so I think
they're spending a ton of money they
both have raised hundreds of millions of
dollars in venture capital and they're
spending that to build out their
networks as quickly as possible and so
they're willing to spend a lot of money
in the short run
to make sure that there is large as uber
somebody who needs a steady paycheck
this is probably not a good choice for
you because we really don't know what
the long-term future is gonna be and
it's hard to predict from week to week
this isn't just something that people do
as a full-time job there are a lot of
people that do it as a supplement to
some other job it can give employees a
lot more freedom because if I feel like
you know not working later today I can
just take the day off and nobody cares
this model isn't for everyone but for
some people it's a great opportunity
[Music]